[__] ybe shout out ble C
[Music]
exclusive check it
out now let's get to this rap [__] I
made a Liv and all music I give a [__]
by a rapist and I don't need a clout
Chase why be been established and when
it comes to these [__] I only [__]
with the baddest what you know about
this life I really rap what I'm on been
in this game for many years and [__] I
still ain't fell off I got the flow they
want to copy cuz they know I'm too raw
I'm looted up we shoot it up if they
come [__] with my dogs I'm underrated
like zo they hate on me I'm like so the
difference is that I be really getting
paid and you don't you mad at me cuz you
broke but [__] go get you alone I'm in
a foreign with a bad and I'm digging
their throat they label this Cho rap cuz
I'm a Mexican rapper but I don't take it
as a disc I tell them thank you I'm
flattered put it down for my people like
it's the fifth of May buing little r
while I'm cruising in the Chevrolet H be
on my grind and they be mad because I'm
undisturbed it's time to talk my [__]
and be unbiased like the hater world I
see so much hate from my people when
it's disgusting don't pull up on me
tripping you threaten me then I'll rush
them that y'all going to gossip [__]
I'm Boston just call me sh ask about me
in the San Gable Valley my name is good
I was raised with infas connected with
INF felons I would never do a song What
you lame so don't expect it I don't care
who gets offended this that West Side
[__] Independence South made we going
worldwide [__] and it's 2023 give me
your Bea and a murder I'm on the mission
trying to be a billionaire like burner
how these rappers flossing chains but
they laid on they rant it's hard for me
to understand that I'm like making make
sense I ain't done this in a minute so I
came out to flex let them know my Flo to
cold and I ain't nothing like the rest
yeah now nevertheless I'm looking fresh
up in my Polo I formed a group but then
I had to go solo Co Ry since so n no
coign I own mind this catalog I hold is
valuable just like a go M I'm giving
them what I got I do this all alone yeah
I pull her to the spot like give me the
microphone yeah go post this on the blog
and let the people know we going viral
now they trying to buy my soul where the
weed at I need that let me see that
let's chief that I say that I'm a stop
but every day I go in relapse buring up
that Hollow tip shout out to the homie n
sgv to the fullest I'm always rapping
for the land yeah I I got that petx that
Mexican Gasolina new coming soon so we
about to blow up your speakers I'm
[__] up this Beast so hard next stop
as Al leakers and Shout Out Bo C iano
rappers and my people
yeah hell yeah ybe rest in peace nipy
let me catch my breath check it
out exclusive baby come on look it's a
close casket killing these rappers they
know my flow Savage late night plotting
and skiing trying to secure the baggage
ski mask give me the loot or we going to
do damage red light stop with the cuz
I'm a loose cannon all I do is get money
so stop with the front and the back up
and leave me alone they yapping about it
but really ain't got it I'm rapping I'm
stacking I'm getting my do I'm in
control I can never let go you mad cuz
I'm better you a in my zone you a On My
Level Now give me the shovel send them
to the devil and burn up his soul I'm on
the way better jump on the boat I'm
killing the game [__] I got the dope I
put out your flame [__] I am the goat m
is the Saye I cannot be clone do like
nothing I'm cting these H you hate it I
love it you know I be stunning I'm
winning and winning I [__] up baby but
hey it's y shout out Bole I think that
was enough any [__] ways uh
[__] ain't easy to do a One Stop shot
one shot kill YB homie let's get it hey
you just watched another freestyle
brought to you by the good Folks at LRG
godamn it shout out to LRG all right go
use the promo code bootleg right now on
their website l-r-g.com say 40% off at
checkout 40% off at checkout use that
promo code and we got another freestyle
coming ASAP